the aviators are on because we are
talking top gun maverick baby and i
absolutely love this movie
[Music]
tom cruise is the goat there is nobody
in hollywood that does action like tom
cruise
once again he's proven he is probably
the biggest movie star in the world and
from the moment that the opening of this
movie hit i was on board now it's not
without its faults we'll talk about that
you know through minor spoilers
throughout this review but if you want
the spoiler-free version of this film it
is awesome absolutely awesome i loved it
all right what's up guys i'm bobby as
you can tell i am pumped all about top
gun maverick i'm super happy this movie
came out in the cinemas i know it's been
delayed multiple times everybody was
saying just release it online and tom
cruise is like no i can't do that and
i'm so glad they waited this movie
deserves to be seen on the big screen
you are going to see visuals you are
going to see uh the cinematography with
the f-18s and
uh
a new prototype
sr-72 variant blackbird jet that just is
going to blow your mind
we have never seen planes film like this
on film before
it's awesome to see
and i get why tom cruise wanted this in
the cinema and i'm glad we waited
because this is a timeless movie it
doesn't matter if it was shot two three
years ago or what it doesn't matter it
is beautiful
awesome okay
anyway let's get into talking a little
bit about the storyline we'll talk about
some minor spoilers and all that great
stuff but man
i'm on board so if you want to wait
watch the movie first you can turn off
the video now then come back after you
watch top gun maverick but if you're all
on for a little bit of spoilers let's
get down to it you're a geek culture we
love our keyboards especially with the
all new logitech mx keys mini an elegant
and functional keyboard its ultra
responsive rounded keycaps are super
stable and quiet for more productivity
there are buttons to enable dictation
microphone audio control and emojis the
backlit keys illuminate when you get
close and matches the lighting of the
environment you're in it lasts up to 10
days on a full charge or 5 months with
the backlights turned off to find out
more about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com
[Music]
top gun maverick opens up pretty much
the exact same way as the original top
gun movie the same music the same
visuals on the aircraft carrier kind of
more modernized a little bit joe
kozinski did a great job translating the
original that tony scott shot and then
he brought his own sort of feel to it
but it's the it's the essence of top gun
which is awesome and as soon as you hear
that theme music man you get chills
through your body if you were a fan of
the original film you are going to love
it okay so after the title sequence is
over we kind of meet pete mitchell he's
uh sort of a test pilot very reminiscent
of a chuck yeager type you know when
he's gotta test out this hypersonic or
supersonic jet that has to hit mach nine
and they've never hit mach nine they've
been testing it for months they've never
hit mach nine i think the closest they
got was mach 7 and they've got a
timeline to hit and they've got this
character kane played by ed harris who's
he's fantastic he's not in the movie
that much which is unfortunate but ed
harris he could do one scene and he just
steals the whole damn thing right he's
that good anyway uh ed harris's
character is all about drones and ai and
robots flying in the future it's not
about pilots but you know maverick is
like hey man i still got i still got the
goods we still can do this anyway
so it's this race against the clock
about hitting mach 9. can maverick do it
can he hit mach 9 or can he go beyond
and i'm not going to tell you what
happens
you kind of probably never knows what
happens because you know the movie this
is just the beginning of the film but
it's the tension and there's nobody who
can fly a plane on film like tom cruise
man the passion
that visceral feeling that you you you
would get being in a cockpit he portrays
that on screen so good
it's awesome to see this man there's no
actor in hollywood that does this man
because he's a pilot himself so he feels
it he portrays it and the speeds they
hit it is
oh man the tingles that you get
man when he puts on that helmet and it
says maverick you're like hell yeah i'm
in for the [ __ ] i'm all in sorry i'm a
little bit pumped up but i really like
this movie okay afterwards
gets his ass chewed out kind of like the
original top gun he gets sent back to
top gun school but he's like for what
and it's to train
pilots for a mission that is almost
impossible
to accomplish
and these pilots are some of the best of
the best that graduated after he did of
course but he's one of the only pilots
you know in top gun uh school that
actually took out three enemy aircraft
at a go which makes him sort of a legend
in the school so he goes back to top gun
school and here's the thing man i'm just
gonna spoil a little bit for you but you
kind of might be already seen this in
the trailers before right he gets on the
original kawasaki ninja man he puts on
the leather jacket puts on the aviators
he says screw the helmet i'm tom cruise
i don't need a helmet hair is blowing
beautifully guy hasn't lost a strand of
hair since he was 22 and he's just
driving down the road having a blast man
it is awesome it is like reminiscent of
the original top gun movie and i loved
every bit of it it's it's a little bit
of fan service hell it's a lot of fan
service but you have a blast watching
this damn thing it is so much fun to
watch anyway gets a top gun school walks
through the halls see his pictures with
uh you know obviously you know iceman
val kilmer with there as well you know
goose all these great all the great
characters from the original top gun
movie they were in there i mean these
guys are somewhat legends in the school
right then he decides to go to a bar
right you know the local kind of bar for
top gun right and then he goes and we
get to meet jennifer connolly right
jennifer connelly man she is absolutely
stunning in this film she's a fantastic
actress but she's beautiful right and
her and tom cruise had a previous
relation i mean term pete mitchell i
should say had a previous relationship
things you know they're not the same
right now but
but
the chemistry between these two you know
something's up and honestly i got to
tell you this right the chemistry
between tom cruise and jennifer connelly
is fantastic you buy this relationship
from the get-go they had a past they
still have the little bit of that love
and feeling between them each other oh
man it is all good it is it's really
good and that relationship really helps
sell the movie going forward because
that's sort of the human element to a
lot of it and that's how they kind of
portrayed this journey with pete
mitchell is jennifer connelly's
character as well it's she's beautiful
and her character's name is penny and
yeah her and pete mitchell just
beautiful then we get to meet rooster
who is goose's son
played by miles teller and this is very
interesting because there's there is a
history there
between pete mitchell
and rooster and uh i call myself sign
because it's much easier for this right
but he looks very much like anthony
edwards from the original uh top gun
even with the same hawaiian shirt the
same glasses the mustache i mean this is
where the fan service is a little bit on
the nose but okay you just go with it
because it's top gun you're like hell
screw it man i'm having a great time
watching this film and he gets on the
the piano plays a little bit of great
balls of fire like his dad did kind of
see some flashbacks from uh when you
know pete and you know and goose were
you know sitting there with meg ryan's
character back in the day they're all
sitting there with the sun on the piano
you know from the original top gun it's
a beautiful moment there but you know
that there's some tension happening with
these two that it's not quite right
anyway
fast forward
so pete mitchell has to train these
pilots and they have to basically they
basically have to do a mission
that is
it's almost unrealistic to complete
you're going to get someone's going to
go down something's going to happen now
jon hamm he's sort of like the one
that's kind of in charge of the top gun
academy and he's the one telling pete
mitchell that hey look man you got to do
this and he's sort of on his ass about
it but the reason that pete mitchell is
there
is because
of admiral kozinski iceman
iceman wants him in top gun to train
these pilots to do this because he
believes that maverick is the only one
that can do this he's the only one now
as we know val kilmer i believe he's
suffering from throat cancer and he no
longer can speak and he's using a voice
box and it's it's very heartbreaking
right
and you always wondered how are they
going to integrate iceman into this film
is they're just going to be you know a
flashback or how are they going to do it
and i'm going to say right now this is
one of the more emotional parts of the
film man you're gonna get you're gonna
have a lot of fuels on this you're gonna
have some tears in your eyes because
it's a beautiful scene when they finally
meet up in person when you see a scene
like this between two characters that
you essentially grow up with you know
you watch top gun countless at times
right and they were always sort of these
friendly adversaries but when you see
him in this moment man it is absolutely
beautiful is awesome
and it's one of the better moments in
the film anyway i love these kind of
movies right i mean i know it's kind of
the 1980s storyline or the 1990s it's
simple in a lot of ways it's like that
last mission that last mission before
you just ride off into the sunset but
damn i love these kind of story lines
anyway
so we get in there
and you find out that these pilots even
though they're pretty good
they really don't know how to dog fight
they really don't know how to maneuver a
plane like maverick and we get to see
some of the best
flying
dog fighting that we've ever seen on
cinema at this point in time it blows
your mind the shots and you're probably
thinking some of this is cgi but from
what i understand most of it is not it's
all real
actual flying footage but the way they
set it up it's like they're flying this
plane so the g-force the way they move
the flying they're weaving in and out is
all real
and they set up all these cameras inside
of it so you get that emotion you get
that
that rawness
that is just amazing to see
honestly i mean i know they're not going
to give top gun any sort of academy
award but this guy deserves some sort of
direct reward because to direct this
kind of action
is fantastic and then this is where you
get the good stuff going man because
they're sitting in this classroom
there's a bit of a spoiler for this
moment okay they're sitting in this
classroom and vice is talking about how
they're going to do this thing they're
changing the timing because you know
maverick wanted to hit this go through
this valley at a certain timing which is
almost impossible for anybody to do none
of the students could do it then all of
a sudden you hear a blip on the screen
and they're like what's that and it's a
plane unidentified aircraft flying and
it's tom cruise and an f-18 hornet going
through this cannon faster than he even
told the students to do it and he does
the whole maneuver the whole mission
and everybody and the students were like
holy [ __ ] this guy is good and then all
of a sudden
the respect for maverick
from the students
to the higher-ups came back and then
vice goes to tom cruise after he lands
and he kind of almost says look i have i
can basically fire your ass i can put
you in you know i can throw you the
throw in jelq you know throw away the
key or whatever the case may be or
we can do another option and he
basically puts him in charge of the
mission he is going to fly this mission
now in between this there's a lot of
tension between him
and rooster you know pete mitchell made
a promise to his mom meg ryan before she
passed away she's not in the film by the
way
a little bit of a spoiler
but why
she didn't want her son to fly she
didn't want her son to face
you know what her husband faced
rightfully so fair enough and i love the
tension between these two and the
chemistry between miles teller and tom
cruise is fantastic it works in this
film anyway so they end up fast forward
they go on to this mission together
and
man you know
it just keeps your hair on your arms is
standing up because the tension
throughout everything how they have to
complete this mission and it's very
reminiscent you know what's funny when
you watch there right this right
if you watch the original star wars new
hope for that matter you know when luke
skywalker is on going through the death
star and he has to fire that missile
into this very small point he's got to
basically use the force
you know but that whole scene where
they're in that sort of valley and
they're flying through that it's very
reminiscent of that as a matter of fact
i'm almost like i'm thinking joe
kozinski and tom cruise are like hell
screw it let's just take from star wars
it worked well for luke skywalker let's
kind of use the same thing for this so
it's very very reminiscent of that
but
what happens
in these pivotal moments throughout that
is after they almost they do they sort
of complete the mission
and then this enemy aircraft comes into
play and then there's a big ass dog
fight going on and it is awesome to see
and then something happens the enemy
aircraft has a lock on rooster
and he's gonna go down
and then
maverick comes in and just blocks it and
he takes the hit and boom
blows up
and you're thinking
[ __ ]
he risked his life for rooster
that's the end of the movie right
because then why says get everybody back
to the aircraft carrier
and the screen goes black
but that's not the end of the movie oh
no it is not
afterwards you cut to tom cruise it was
on it he was at a parachute he would
land it on the ground in this kind of
winter snowy area
and
then all of a sudden you see this this
attack helicopter i don't know exactly
what it is comes over and it's firing on
him and it's firing on him and it's
pretty much that's it he's done and then
all of a sudden boom helicopter goes
rooster came back for maverick baby he
came back against orders to save him
then boom his plane gets knocked out so
then he parachutes and lands this is
where it gets a pseudo corny but by this
time you're already bought into all the
fan service and you're like aw screw it
man let's just go for it right they're
like we gotta get out of here because
there's a base where this uh this
mission was being held at and inside
this base
this is funny [ __ ] right inside this
base is an f-14 tomcat
yes the same plane
that maverick and goose were flying
in the original todd gun movie and
so maverick gets in the plane roosters
in the back just like his dad back in
the day they're flying through this
whole damn thing
and i gotta tell you man they uh going
through this mission
you know in their own i mean these enemy
aircraft are like fifth generation
planes they're way advanced more than
what the americans have
they get to a moment and then bam this
character called hangman saves their ass
out of it who's played by glenn powell
by the way who's like a modern version
of iceman he's fantastic in this movie i
don't want to say too much about it but
he's in this movie quite a bit but he's
like an ice man of the era and he saves
their ass you know snarky remark get
someone saved crowd gets on the aircraft
carried just like the original cheering
everybody on the mission is complete
they rescued everybody it's all good
and then you get to the point
where one of the best lines in cinema we
have heard in years
this is said
between tom cruise and miles teller and
i'm not going to tell you what this is
but the moment that this
just a couple lines were said man i had
tears
coming down my face
it was so beautiful
it was so poignant
oh my god man it made it it just was
beautiful it was absolutely awesome
there's no political agenda here
there's no uh
pc-ness going on in this there's nothing
about this
you know you watch a lot of films
nowadays they're always trying to put
some hidden subliminal message in there
about you know society or government or
you know the left or the right and bad
and good and all that stuff no it's not
there man and as a matter of fact when
you talk about the the enemy they never
mention a country it's not like russia
or china or anybody else out there that
america news is talking about it's none
of that you don't even know
so
what's great is this film can play
anywhere in the world
and it's not negative to any country
which is great and i'm glad that they
did this because you know what we've got
enough politics from american news out
there on tv nowadays we don't need to
see it in the cinemas all the time and
i'm glad that tom cruise and joe
kaczynski and the production team went
this route and tom cruise knows exactly
what to do with the sequel he knows what
the fans want to see and he delivers it
and he does it beautifully and i've said
that many times in this review but it's
because it's true
it's everything i wanted to see in a top
gun sequel and does it set up for a
third one
those are my thoughts on top gun
maverick let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below i absolutely
love this movie the aviators are back on
because
i feel the need
the need for speed subscribe to the
channel like this video and i'll chat to
you soon take care
[Music]
you